okay let's talk about the idea that
people on the Left want Trump to fail
and they want the country to fail just
to hurt Donald Trump the right has been
saying this for a while and they claim
that they the leftists the Democrats the
progressives the Socialists the Marxists
whatever category even if it's one that
barely exists in the United States they
all want Trump to fail merely to prove
and score political points and of course
I've argued that this is ridiculous
for a very long time I've said before
that when Trump fails we all fail when
Donald Trump is an embarrassment
internationally in front of our
so-called allies or our previous allies
who Donald Trump alienates we all lose
when other countries stop including the
United States in discussions about
climate change doesn't matter whether
you voted for Trump or not we all lose
if Donald Trump fails in North Korea
people could die and we all lose if
Donald Trump fails on the economy
everybody could end up losing their job
or losing their money regardless of
whether you voted for Donald Trump or
not and in the midst of this we are
presented with this reality that the
stock market downturn is it time to call
it a crash continues and we are now as
of yesterday's closing down for the year
on the Dow Jones Industrial Average the
entire year of gains that Donald Trump
has been tweeting about has evaporated
you'll notice that the Dow opened on
Tuesday January 2nd the first trading
day of the year at 24,000 824 and closed
yesterday nearly 300 points below that
at 24,000 583 the S&P 500 which is a
broader index than the Dow Jones
likewise
closed yesterday down for the year in
the interim new home sales have dropped
to the lowest rate in two years great
timing for me I just moved I just have a
mazing timing impeccable I hate this ok
I didn't vote for Trump I'm reporting to
you what's going on but trust me when I
log in to my mutual fund account
I feel physical pain I am NOT cheering
this I do not want Trump to preside over
a crashings
market and the idea that there are
people on the left hoping that Trump
fails in these ways that worsen
circumstances for everybody is
ridiculous my most leftist friends who I
speak to you privately they didn't vote
for Trump they don't like Trump's policy
they don't agree with this worldview not
a single one of them is saying I hope
Trump fails on the economy or this or
that because they all want to live in a
better place I think it depends though
how you frame it like I want him to
succeed when it comes to the economy at
large but you want to get voted out
things I don't want his tax cuts to
succeed I don't want his tariffs to
succeed because I understand that those
are bad for the economy you disagree
with the agenda and hope he fails to
implement it but that doesn't mean that
you're hoping for the country to be
worse off we're hoping for the country
to be as well-off as possible now it's
important to mention when it comes to
stocks speculative markets are not a
direct indicator of economic health I
say this when stocks are up when it's a
Democrat in the White House and when
stocks are down when it's a Democrat in
the White House and likewise whether
stocks are up or down when it's a
Republican in the White House the stock
market also doesn't affect everyone and
the stock market can move significantly
simply based on speculation that being
said the moves do affect many people and
even if you don't personally own
significant amounts of stocks or mutual
funds you might work for a company whose
success and ability to keep hiring
people and paying people is linked to
how things are going in the stock market
and we we know that humans generally are
not great at predicting the future of
stock markets in the future of the
economy we've been talking about the
idea that at some point the next
pullback is going to happen there are
analysts now saying this is the
beginning of it that this is just the
beginning of the fall others saying now
the stock market has worked out the
kinks by giving back all of the gains of
2018 and that from here on out it's just
going to be positive doesn't matter the
point is this does affect
a lot of people in different ways the
right deliberately obfuscates you know
Trump tweets on individual days when
stocks are up today we may have a
rebound gain right by the time people
listen to or watch this we may have had
a gain today that would get us a few
hundred points above where we started
the year and then there's absolute and
total silence on these days where the
Dow crashes four six or eight hundred
points you've got to look at the broader
numbers you have to understand the
context here but these are not good
indicators the housing market and the
stock market right now are not pointing
well yeah it's either utter silence from
Trump or he'll try to blame it on the
Fed raising interest rates or something
like hurricane Michael but at any rate
it's not the fault of him or his policy
and it's funny because the gains in the
stock market he of course wouldn't
attribute to low interest rates which
are decided by the Fed they would be
attributed in Trump's mind to his
economic policy and then of course as
soon as you have these downturns in the
stock market it's because of something
the Fed is doing or what somebody else
is doing or what's going on with Saudi
Arabia and instability in that market
which is affecting ours because hey we
live in a globalized world and we don't
just exist in a silo where our stock
market is completely unconnected to what
goes on elsewhere in the world I hope
this isn't the beginning of a big crash
I don't want that to be the case I don't
care that Trump will take credit for the
gangs I don't want a crash it's sad when
I log into my mutual fund account that's
the reality what else can I say make
sure you're following me on instagram at
David Pakman I'll post some behind the
scenes pictures of the studio move that
is starting to happen after today's show
and you can also follow the show on
instagram at david pakman show we want
to get to 10,000 followers on the show
account on Instagram that's the
immediate goal we've caught it like 3200
right now so we're well on our way yeah
we will take a quick break after the
break much awaited our long-form piece
on Jordan Peterson stay with us
today's program sponsored in part by
blinkers comm slash Pakman I've talked
about blinkers before it's this awesome
app that I've been using for several
months now and what it does is take the
best and most critically acclaimed
on fiction books and condenses them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to in one sitting you could listen to
ten books in an afternoon I know that
many in our audience want to expand
their horizons and learn more about all
sorts of different topics but we're
mostly limited by time to some degree I
know I'm not able to read all of the
books that I want simply because I've
got other stuff going on and that's why
blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to be li NK is t-dot-com slash PA k ma n